[Music]
let's go
d4
once again we're playing queens gambit
we are playing queens gambit and we're
facing a london system this is great
this is the first time that we have
faced
the london system
um and
there's a million
setups against the london that
i can recommend to people in the
beginner category but
i'm going to recommend a
a setup that's a little bit complicated
but i think you guys can can handle it
and that's
this is also the move that i play at the
highest level
which is sort of to play this like a
reverse queen's gambit and play c5 and
i'm sure everybody in the chat is
familiar with it you've probably seen
this move before
and it works exactly the same way that a
queen's gambit does okay d takes e5 now
we'll be able to demonstrate it
now we got to be a little bit more
careful because white's bishop is
already on f4 so normally we would be
able to play e5 but here we can't play
it
now
we can play e6 but that's not the most
flexible movie six is possible
but then white is able to cling to the
pawn with the move before so how should
we begin
what should black do here what's the
most accurate move
what's the most accurate move who can
tell me
knight c6 is correct the knight c6
accomplishes a couple of things it
prevents b4 develops the knight and it
prepares e5
we're threatening the movie five knight
c3 okay
that's not a good move and we have
multiple ways to respond to it of course
we can play e5 anyway
um or we can send it with the move uh d4
and that very important detail you guys
should be always aware of d4 knight b5
uh queen a5 check of course wins the
night because
you should be especially um attentive to
this given that the white light squared
bishop is
is not controlling the b5 score which
means that these tactics are always
going to be on the horizon
in terms of which of these moves i would
play i think starting with e5 makes
sense and then following up with d4
um so we attack the bishop we get
control of the center
black is already better knight c3 is a
mistake it's not really in the spirit of
london now in addition to d4 we could
also play the more conservative move
knight f6 developing the knight
but
you know d4 has no downsides and a lot
of people how do i know that it's a good
idea to push the pawns here well
it
here pushing the pawns isn't a
particularly ambitious thing well it is
ambitious it's just not risky right i
mean these puns are still very well
protected and there we go knight p5
very common blunder at this level
uh if you've done your puzzle rush you
should see queen a5 check automatically
in any such position
boom
it's going to open the window
c3
and thank you for the night
and it's over okay e3 and now total
collapse
so
very important whenever you win a piece
right don't
i see this very often somebody will
blunder a piece and then on the next
move they will counter blunder because
there's a
unwitting process of relaxation where
you say all right i basically won the
game so in this position for example
some people just take on e3 and blunder
the queen
what should we do
which pawn should we take should we take
on c5 or should we take on b2
is it dangerous to take off v2 could our
queen get trapped there
the answer to that question is
what do you guys think
no of course it's not going to get
trapped there's way too much real estate
we're threatening queen takes c3 white's
got nothing developed yeah rook b1
attacks the queen congrats
but
now we take another pawn with check and
we're just taking everything
now we're just taking i mean white has
to play queen d2 and essentially go for
the queen trade and okay king e2
yeah so winning these positions fast is
i
it
is a tough skill
um
and the first thing that you should
immediately see here and i think
everybody notices this is the alignment
of the king and the queen who should
lead you to consider the move bishop g4
check
now you might reject this move because
in response white has the move f3 but if
you just calculate one move further in
that situation we have what move bishop
g4 check f3
and anytime a pawn like this is pushed
you should be considering which other
squares are weakened
and in that situation the e3 square is
weakened and that's just checkmate which
g4 check is very strong if knight f3 we
of course play e4 yeah checkmate
quick one
very quick one
and then move c5 is
uh is quite dangerous at a beginner
slash early intermediate level so c5
now i don't know what uh eric rosen
recommends here white has many moves
and d takes c5 is a totally legitimate
move if it's followed up correctly
the the most sort of londony move here
is either e3 or c3
um e3 being
you know my preferred move as
as white probably
so e3
and then black plays knight c6 anyway
white can play knight f3 here y can play
and actually c3 is is the way that
the theory goes
and
yeah black just plays knight f6
and and here
there's a lot of theory i mean i i
recommend i mean particularly those of
you watching on youtube
i'm not gonna delve too deeply into the
theory here that's outside the scope of
the speedrun rosen
levy i mean tons of videos on the london
on youtube and this line i'm sure is
covered
uh but the one subtlety that i'll
mention here is that in in recent times
92 i i believe has
you know don't quote me on this but i'm
i'm pretty sure this is the best way to
start for white if white plays knight f3
who can tell me
uh what relatively nasty idea does black
have here this is
this has been around for many many years
this particular sequence
and i think according to modern theory
this line is is considered quite good
for black
so queen b6 the veronica is correct
queen v6 now generally in the london
white responds with queen b3
now you play c4
now you play c4
the point being and i've talked about
this this end game is is generally very
comfortable for black because of the
idea of b5 b4 and black has control of
the a file
so black white usually plays queen c2
and now very important move this pawn on
b2 is highly vulnerable and black has
bishop f5
and black has bishop f5
um
queen takes f5 queen takes b2 and the
rook is lost now there's a very
important detail white has to play queen
c1 for that reason after e6 black is
extremely comfortable in this position
according to modern theory so knight d2
evades this because after queen b6 which
is still a legitimate move
c4 queen c2 of course bishop f5 is no
longer a move because the rook has space
to move
now a word of caution about this
particular idea of
of distraction or deflection right
deflection tactics can backfire
spectacularly
reflection tactics can
can backfire spectacularly
especially in this line let me see if i
can find
uh this game here just give me a moment
please
so there was a game that i was watching
uh this was the tournament that i was
playing in spain
uh two very strong players so d45 knight
f3 c5 e3 that's the kali system knight
c6
so bishop e2 takes takes bishop g4
c3 e6 queen b3 so this time it's white
who's the aggressor and after queen c7
white sort of automatically plays the
move bishop f4
now slightly different idea right the
rook is not trapped but the knight's
gonna hang after queen f4 queen b7 but
it turns out that this is not the end of
the story black took the bishop after
queen takes b7
uh
it transpires that black has this
incredibly nasty check on c1 and
something cool happens bishop d1
bishop takes f3
now this looks unthinkable
take the rook with check
take the bishop but after queen takes b2
the it turns out that the white rook is
trapped the position remains extremely
messy i think this is equal according to
uh the engines but
the point is that you have to be very
careful uh about misapplying this trap
so back to the game back to the game
it's total chaos
e3 knight c6 c3 is the recommended line
i believe by by most sources d takes c5
is
very good but after knight c6 white has
to play knight f3
and this is an important move to prevent
e5
and then uh
well and then black can play e6 here
uh black can also play knight f6 i think
that's the main move
and things get messy here i mean e3 e6
is sort of a reverse queen scan but
accepted which is
you know basically equal i mean i can
play c4 bishop c5 knight c3 this type of
position
nothing to write home about but very
solid for black
more
uh testing is the move c3
and oftentimes this leads to this type
of position where
white clings to the pawn black tries to
attack it you guys have seen
these types of situations before in many
openings
including in the speedrun so you can dig
around here on your own with opening
explore these are very interesting
positions to to analyze they teach you a
lot about imbalances in the center
that's why i decided to play c5 in in
any case knight c3 is a pretty serious
mistake
and
you know common again a common beginner
mistake unfamiliar position you kind of
resort to natural development without
fully assessing the specifics of the
position right the specifics is that e5
is a threat and it turns out that knight
c3 only walks right into
this sequence so where should the knight
have gone
what should white have done here to at
least maintain
a reasonable position
oh man i don't even know that white can
maintain a reasonable position because
i think white has to play knight back to
b1
because originally i was going to tell
you guys knight e4
but
who can tell me
what incredibly nasty sequence and i
just spotted this myself what does black
have here
bishop gets trapped f5
knight t6 check
takes takes boom
bishop is trapped and lost so white is
in huge trouble here i mean knight b1 is
necessary and then just in the mid look
at this position pawns everything's
developed
f5 is coming knight f6 is coming white
is in trouble but at least this
kept kept white in the game knight p5
quinn a5 check his game over
pretty simple not much to not much to
say here i think we could definitely get
another game in
you guys desire
knight oh yeah knight a4 oh oh oh knight
e4 i agree knight a4 is the move knight
a4 is the move because if queen a5 check
here there's c3 in white
there's more or less
white is more or less still in the game
this is probably
the best option because it also keeps c5
relatively protected
all right
let's go e4
c5
and
we're still working on c3 sicilian
that's been our opening that's still our
opening it's just it's just the best
sicilian in my opinion anywhere under
1900
okay so e6 common common response
at at this level
common response at this level the
movie's six
and of course we played d4
yeah and c takes d4 is already knackered
who can explain to me why c takes d4 is
inaccurate because
okay this trade doesn't look bad for
black there is a specific thing that
this
gives white which is unnecessary to
allow thank you luke lex
well no it doesn't give up the full
center because black can play d5 and
contest the center
we get c3 for the night yeah we get c3
for the night and that that allows us to
have almost a perfect french position
assuming that our opponent plays d5
which he doesn't it goes knight f6
now here a lot of people i know would be
tempted to go e5 alakan style but no
need to give up the d5 square e5 black
goes knight d5
and um
you know the knight entrenches itself on
that weak square
so
definitely in this position we want to
go
uh knight c3
develop bishop b4 as we'll see is
nothing to be afraid of i know it
probably concerns some of you that this
move exists but
it's it's not scary for specific reasons
and he plays it
why is it not scary again i don't
necessarily want to play e5
i don't necessarily want to play 5 auto
makes waves is absolutely correct
not f3 we certainly don't want to play
f3 that
that's a very weakening move never play
f3 especially in the opening
thank you adriana for the raid
92 is not good because it doesn't defend
against knight takes e4 you're defending
the knight but not the pawn
uh bishop g5 is a common mistake as well
who can explain before we play bishop d3
which is correct
what's wrong with bishop g5 because this
is very instructive
and i i explained this previously but
it's important to reiterate
no yeah queen a5 is annoying yeah yeah
definitely queen a5 but that's not
actually the reason that i was had in
mind
i'm not playing bishop g3 and bishop d3
unless somebody explains
why bishop g5 is bad eight yeah exactly
so bishop g5 black plays h6
this is what people often miss you might
say well i just go bishop h4 no big deal
well it is a big deal black then plays
g5 chase is the bishop and don't forget
about the e4 pawn it's going to be
hanging after the bishop gets away so
you don't always want to defend upon
with a counter pin
that can be a very flimsy way to defend
now it's not the end of the world we
would have taken the knight but why give
up the dark square bishop and make two
moves right okay knight c6 obviously we
go
knight f3 we can also go knight e2 by
the way 92 is not a stupid move at all
but i'm already smelling a greek gift
sacrifice here so let's go knight f3
if if i understand how this game is
going to go correctly we might
give it a 25 chance
of a greek gift sacrifice that is
contingent on black playing d5
and then castling and going like knight
d7 after d5 is played okay so of course
in this position we do not want to take
the pawn
that allows black to take with the
knight and get an isolated queen pawn
position with a blockade
the move here of course is to push e5
this should be
completely clear to everybody
okay so 94
is the best move here and i'm
yeah he plays that doesn't fully
eliminate the possibility of
a greek gift
but it
okay so we have a
look i'll put it this way
we have a really adventurous move here
which i would hesitate to play in a
speedrun but i'm going to play it anyway
because it's instructive
so the
okay so yeah castles is the adventurous
move just sacking on c3 and prioritizing
development
bishop d2 i don't like i i do not like
giving up the dark square bishop in this
position why
largely because the d4 pawn is on a dark
square and i want to be able to defend
it with bishop e3 later on
right i'm worried about that pawn
becoming a weakness
queen c2 is the clinical move queen c2
stops all threats it's a nice little
move
it pressures the knight
but in this house
i like tactical moves so we castle
and if you've played the italian if you
play the main line italian you should
recognize the similarity between this
idea what we're doing here
and one of the lines in the italian
which i will show
after the game concludes
now rugby one isn't even forced here we
have yeah bishop a3 as some of you are
indicating is a very much legitimate
uh idea sacking the exchange but
preventing black from castling and
getting
essentially total domination on
the dark squares
uh but rugby one is also an incredibly
tricky move
so
rugby one castles perhaps allows the
greek gift we'll think about it
who can tell me rugby one knight takes
d4 if you've been paying attention the
previous game you should be able to tell
me how knight takes d4 is refuted
after rook b1
and we're going to go rook b1 we're
going to
go with a slightly less adventurous move
nope and that's the muppet most popular
wrong answer not the immediate queen a4
check
because the knight returns to c6
remember always remember this about
forking a knight in a king very often
the knight can return and block the fork
how do we solve this problem well think
about it we can take the knight first
and now actually there are two ways we
can play bishop b5 check sorry no agree
gift
because we'll end up winning a full
piece instead not the worst
uh turn of events but i like this move
why why do i like this more than bishop
v because i want to keep this bishop
right if he castle short i want to keep
this bishop that bishop is going to
attack the king and because we don't
have the knight anymore greek gift is
out of the question
um
no reason
that i see not to take on b7 that's a
perfectly juicy free pawn
and we could have gone for
a more immediate attack but
you know you don't want to take that too
far you don't want to go crazy you want
to take what's given to you
yeah we'll talk about bishop takes first
we'll talk about bishop takes first that
was a more resilient move rather than
knight takes d4
so i always talk about this i feel like
i'm almost obsessed over it at the start
of the spirit and it's the question of
how do i know when to take material and
when to go for an attack given that i'm
i'm already up material
rick takes b7 doesn't disrupt the
coordination of your pieces
to the contrary right the rook on b7 is
great now where should we go
where should we go with the rook a lot
of people i think would just drop back
to b1 but you have to squeeze the most
out of the retreat
yeah you guys you guys have to have the
right sense oh yeah first of all we can
take on a7 absolutely fine but now let's
go for the attack
we've we've had our fill of the queen
side pods let's go for the attack
rook b3 bingo
why because once the bishop gets away
from d3 this rook is gonna swing to the
king's side look at black's king there's
nothing around black's king it's gonna
be made and especially now
oh and now we've got
all manner of ideas all manner of ideas
oh
the question here is do we want to play
fancy schmancy or do we want to just win
yeah you know
bishop takes h7 is not as simple as you
guys think it is
bishop takes h7 is not as clear cut as
you guys think it is but we're gonna
play it
we're gonna play it and i'm gonna
convince you that this is not as clear
as as it is it's winning for sure we're
gonna win but
these sacks can be
difficult now
very popular well not a mistake here but
people think that queen h4 king g8 rook
h3 leads to immediate checkmate it does
not
remember this
why who can who can tell me why
yeah white will win but it's not
actually made and you got to be very
careful about this
the move f6 yeah f6 opens up this
pathway for the king and although this
is winning here because of the
overwhelming number of pieces if you've
sacrificed more than we did it could be
a big problem
so
what the thing to understand is that
page 3 h4 is not the only way to attack
right and i would start with queen h4
check that's a flexible flexible way to
start
and what move am i thinking of in this
position
and this is a constructive concept of
not only looking at the open files right
not only looking at the open files
looking at the semi-open files as well
this pod on g7 is a pretty pitiful cover
right
so what i like is the move rook g3
this sets up queen f6 it sets up bishop
h6 the sac on g7 is not out of the
question to me this looks a lot more
overwhelming than starting to hunt the
king after rook h3f6 a little bit
less clean although as i'll show you
after the game rook h3 was also
completely completely winning
so multiple options here for sure
dark squares by the way don't look at
the dark squares boom boom
again accuracy is crucial in these
positions do not rush
and make sure you're fully properly
considering your opponent's defensive
resources for example a lot of people
would go queen f6 here
leading with the queen in an attack is
dangerous that can be a big mistake
why why is queen f6 a mistake
now rook h3 is mate on the spot
queen d8 queen d8 and we got to go back
we could play bishop g5 that would be an
excellent move and bishop f6 but just
because an idea wasn't applied on one
move doesn't mean it can't be applied on
the next idea improvement rook h3 i saw
a great example of that just recently
and i'll show you guys
now it wins on the spot it's mate
because now the move f6 allows queen h7
as he's thinking i mean the game is over
it's made on the next move
i'm going to pull up
a great example of this kind of
flexible thinking and a very similar
theme actually
in in a
exercise that i recently gave to a
student
okay so let's finish the game
so let's begin
by
applying that idea of idea improvement
so and the concept of weak dark squares
so white to play here de britson against
bench bone later became a gm i'm not i'm
not familiar with the player with white
1977.
okay so it's white to play and win in
this position
let's look at this position for a second
see what we can notice you should notice
in particular two
uh big big trump cards for white the
first of course is
the pawn on d6 is a monster and the
second is that
uh blacks dark squares are horrendously
catastrophically weak
um
so the first movement wow you guys are
are very very sharp
first move is d7 and that's pretty uh
pretty straightforward we advance the
pawn we hit the rook
black cannot take on d7 because then the
queen hangs so we're there is force
now the rook on the e8 is a sitting duck
and we play queen f6
but the hard part comes after queen
takes d7 why to play and win and i
advise you to take your time there is a
trap here that you have to sidestep with
a very very nice move
very good bishop h6 is the muppet
we d4 between d4 x-ray defense g7 black
is okay what we have to do is play
bishop g5 first hit the rook
only after the rook moves do we play
bishop h6 and now queen d4 is no longer
possible mate is inevitable
yeah nice stuff and another nice line
occurs after rook takes d7
here we cannot dislodge the rook from
the
from the uh d file but what you have to
notice is that the back rank is now
terribly weak thank you tifa gifting to
maximus so bishop h6 queen d4
and very nice one
and this is unstoppable black can try
bishop b6
but it's not helping rook takes c6 fe 6
queen f8 made very pretty and notice
that white's created luft none of this
would have worked if i didn't have lift
literally none of this not a single line
because of constant threat of mate
so
lessons you know just because an idea
doesn't work in one version does it mean
you can't start with an intermezzo
and and solve the problem
um and it works on the next and it
doesn't mean you have to forget about it
for all time
okay back to the game
back to the game
so
this is instructive yeah takes takes if
you watch my uh or if you bought my
nerdsy method i
one of the shortest games i've ever
played against the 1700
actually started exactly like this
the best move for black here is d5
immediately and potentially this
transposes into an advanced french which
a lot of people don't want to play
but the move in the aleppo styles he
takes d5 got plenty of speedrun games in
this line
so you can uh
dig around
cdcdi also have plenty of games in this
position
okay knight f6 is fine
the best move is d5 either here or on
the next move
um
okay so bishop b4 bishop d3 let's get to
the fun part knight c6 knight f3 d5 e5
knight e4
and and yeah i was hoping for a great
gift after 97 castles castles boom this
is a classic like a classic greek gif
knight g5 check etc
and as a good exercise those of you
watching on youtube i'm actually not
going to analyze this deliberately see
if you can set it up on a board and
figure out how white wins after king g6
king h6 and king g8
and see if you can work that out without
an engine
okay so 94 castles
um
very thematic concept of giving up the
c3 pawn thank you digital hobo
so
knight takes c3 bc bishop c3
and a lot of you are yeah bishop a3 is
is is is a concept straight from the
italian this just shows you how
important it is to be aware of multiple
openings i keep talking about this and
preaching it in the speed run this is
the
sort of old school italian pawn
sacrifice it's the greco attack yeah and
and basically takes
takes
um takes
uh this line
and now um well it's not exactly bishop
a3 is not the move here
although i guess it is a move but queen
b3 is the best move
takes bishop f7 and bishop g5 is i
believe this is the best line this wins
for white and a7 is this is crushing
uh but you can see the similarity you
can see the similarity so 94
castles takes takes takes rook b1 is
what we decided on
partially because i was still hoping for
a great gift sacrifice
a lot of people were asking well what
happens after bishop takes d4
so again a bishop a3 according to
deronicus is called the aid cannon is
also very dangerous totally believe it
this guy at night
not
well
we can play queen a4 check but
it doesn't win a piece now there's two
moves i could recommend here the first
is what
the first is positional the second is
tactical let's put it this way i would
play the second i think it just wins on
the spot
knight on d4 is very much weak
pawn on g7 is also undefended pattern
recognition queen g4
boom boom knight can drop back to f5
here we take it
take on g7 bishop a3 and black and
resign that's definitely the best line
but nothing wrong with the positional
bishop a3 as well the king is never
going to be able to castle that is the
horrible thing about giving up
a bishop of a particular color people
don't realize that that is on the same
level sometimes it's like blundering
your queen you are never going to be
able to castle
unless you i don't know miraculously get
rid of this bishop
um this is a totally lost position
white's going to play queen g4 i don't
know f4 f5 is an idea
it's just over thank you square v visor
an extremely common mistake to give up
a bishop of a particular color
at all levels without realizing that
the comeuppance is
you know
you're not going to get the sickness
until later
um and and a lot of people struggle to
understand this they think well there's
no immediate threats
so
i'm i'm safe to give away my bishop but
um
but eventually the squares of a
particular color are going to come back
to bite you and i have a good example of
that
i have an example of that
from one of my games a little bit more
complicated but hopefully it'll
reinforce that theme
hopefully it'll reinforce that theme
this is from
world youth chess champion oops no i
don't want to upgrade world youth chess
championship
uh 20 2008 i was 2300 my opponent is
2100.
um let's flip the board
okay so this was the king's indian
samish
i'm gonna kind of fast forward to the
important moment this is the sameish
variation king's indian you've seen me
play this on stream many times
vietnam that's correct
okay so eventually we get this position
knight h5
my opponent goes g4 very quickly and
confidently thinking that i have
blundered
because knight f4 loses a pawn
and going back to f6 is terrible right
white's just going to start the attack
what do you think i did
of course knight f4 this is completely
automatic in the king's indian
and the whole point is that after bishop
f4 ef look at these dark squares look at
that bishop it's gonna be a monster my
opponent to his credit didn't take
immediately goes knight g2
a lot of people here i think would
take on d3
or a g5 no need just leave the knight on
f4
here he couldn't resist he takes it
and what's worse my knight comes to c5
my queen comes to f6 now he plays a
terrible move he takes on c5
thinking well i've got these center
pawns
you know they're gonna start moving and
not realizing that these dark squares
are just gonna kill him watch what
happens bishop b2 b4
knight b1 c4
g5 queen d6 bishop takes c4 i sack a
second pawn look at these squares bishop
e5 now this is threatened
a5
a4 a3 and look at look at these squares
now bishop back to g7 setting up a
battery this is crushing everything
happens along the dark squares every one
of my moves is on a dark square now i go
to this diagonal that diagonal
and eventually i just took a bunch of
his pawns and then i started pushing my
pawns the wind was not as smooth as it
could have been
but it was uh
it was very thematic
and the final position is really really
nice the lesson here is that uh the
weakness of a particular color square
is often worth sacrificing for
oftentimes even more than just a pawn
and even sometimes a queen
uh and the second part of that is that
square weaknesses aren't
can be delayed right you can weaken a
square and you have to realize that that
can be exploited later
um people sometimes have that
short-sighted approach
to that
to that idea okay so back to the game
uh hopefully i was
explaining bishop takes d4
okay knight d4 is is
game over right after queen a4 check but
what should black have done here if i
was playing black i would probably drop
the bishop back to b4 to prevent bishop
a3
again rook takes before does not win the
night the knight drops back to c6
so if i were white here
multiple i mean i'd have to think
but even a slow move like bishop e3
could be considered because castles
always runs into bishop takes h7
you could also consider the more
aggressive knight g5 followed by queen
h5
that might be the best line and i think
white is still dominating here but at
least black is in the game
okay so it takes the bishop takes the
pawn
back to b3
bishop takes h7 and again rook h3 queen
h4 as i was discussing
is not as clear-cut as perhaps it should
be although here after queen h7 and e
takes f6 i'm sure that white is also
completely winning completely winning
i can give you right off the bat like a
million examples of games where
white goes for this kind of sacrifice
it looks
you know totally winning and black plays
f6 and takes the air completely out of
everything
so
let me see if i can do a little search
here
yeah this is a nice game
look at this game some random game from
bulgarian championship 1955 which nobody
has ever seen before
yeah so
white goes for this crazy attack
black just very calmly attacks the queen
side b5 b4
and now f6 and white sacks everything
and nothing works e5
bishop b takes c3 check check looks very
scary king takes e6 no problem rookie
one check back to f7 boom
king takes e7
queen takes g7 check rook f7
rookie three check it looks like black
has blundered
who can tell me why
mr philip philippov
in fact did not blunder what is the
crushing game here thank you doug
maverick of course queen e5 takes and
now which one do you take with f takes
e5 is even better
and checkmate on f1 so
you get the point don't fall in love
with an attack that proceeds on exactly
one file it might not be as dangerous as
you think
not trying to take the air out of the
building here but
that's the point here and that's why
although this of course is completely
winning for different reasons
but rook g3 in my opinion is a lot more
clear-cut queen h4 and rook g3
um
and the point is that now f6 meets with
he takes f6 which is totally crushing
because of this
he thought he was hot yeah exactly g6 or
h3 is me
there's nothing else that that black can
do if black tries this move
then uh i think the simplest
no the best is to play queen h queen up
to h6 forcing g6 and now again rook h3
is me
oh yeah that's another idea that's the
fischer benko idea
okay
yeah g6 or kh3 f5 in h7 now that we have
provoked more weaknesses we go right
nothing much to say here i mean the
attack is quite simple
don't get too stressed out about like oh
i didn't see that move how do you find
this
a lot of attacking skill
consists in
actually looking at games like tall
games explained games
tons of resources on youtube
and then trial and error you know over
sacrificing sometimes embarrassing
yourself a little bit
seeing what works and what doesn't and
ultimately getting a sense of how
attacks work
every attack is
different yeah and i have many examples
of situations where
i also on the other side got terrified
of an attack
um which in reality was not all that
dangerous well i had a very embarrassing
moment in the
2510 i'm playing the eventual winner
sahaja grover who's now a grand master i
played a phenomenal game with black and
i was i was afraid of him he was the top
seed and in this position which we
reached yeah through an eye door if he
goes knight g5 he offers me a draw
knight g5 offers me a draw
and i'm like sitting there i'm basically
shaking i'm like oh my god he's gonna go
knight f7 he's literally gonna smothered
mate me
i saw the black as the defense
but i i just
i was just too scared and i also
miscalculated a line that i thought led
to perpetual who can tell me how black
simply disarms white's quote-unquote
non-attack
queen c4 is not correct because if queen
takes c4 and don't forget about the back
rank
so don't get tunnel vision
queen c6 is also incorrect because of
knight f7 shack and knight h6 this isn't
prevent the smothered mate
queen c1 doesn't prevent the smothered
mate
queen c1
the smothered mate does not depend on
the rook folks
and pinned pieces protect so you can't
go king f8 here this is still smothered
me
same with queen f2 the move is h6 you
have to create space for the king
after knight f7 check simply king h7 the
queen is doing an excellent job it's
defending the rook and it's defending
all of the squares on this diagonal
now
i thought that white has a perpetual
here if he wants it with knight g5 check
h takes g5 and now queen h3 check and i
calculated king g8
uh queen e6 check
perpetual but of course my fear had
overtaken me and i missed a very simple
idea which is what
king g6 yeah queen e6 jack and of course
bishop drops back and covers the check
yeah
oh by the way last thing i know i'm on a
big detour here
in such positions where the king is cut
off along two files
uh be careful about the move g4
this kind of move can be incredibly
difficult to stop
queen h5 mate is a huge threat
how should black respond to this why is
this not
scary
yeah because of queenie for check king
ji won bishop d4 with total destruction
and if rook f3 then of course i mean
there's multiple ways to mate here rook
c1 check etc
but
just as a
rule of thumb do uh
do keep this idea in mind of basically
going g5 at the right moment
and creating a stronghold on
h4 i once missed an idea like this as a
gm
okay this position where black is quite
clearly winning
uh look at white's king just look at
black's position and in this position i
played
queen h6 check
king g3 and g5 and ultimately i won the
game pretty easily with a big attack
but i missed an amazing combination now
the first move this combination i saw
in fact i saw the main idea but i missed
the subtlety
idea improvement who can tell me the
first move the first move is quite
natural in my opinion it gets rid of one
of white's main defensive pieces
the first move is queen h6 check this is
correct in this position rook takes e5
is best
because after if you play this
immediately after fe 5 quinn h6 the king
can come back to g1 you're supposed to
give a check first
now you take on e5 and again uh d takes
c5
queen takes e4 so f takes e5
black to play
let's see who's been paying attention
but this is a trick there there's a mass
there's a brilliant move in this
position
and now everybody thinks g5 i tricked
you guys g5 is incorrect and this is
what i saw
g5 is incorrect because
yeah jose got it because of rook h1
so idea improvement you don't abandon
the id you say wait a second i need to
discoordinate these rooks you take on d4
brilliant move
yeah jose jose got it
threading bishop e5 white has to take
and so you go g5 and now queen h4 is
unstoppable exactly the same idea
amazing move
deflection deflection i mean why can't
play rook h1 you take it it's over
so
just be aware of this idea but anyways
that was a good example of an
embarrassing game
um
where i i you know my fear of the attack
got the better of me
i played as i said i played g5
immediately but
i didn't play with the same idea i mean
i just wanted to open up the king i won
easily i just
sort of won by by trading queens and
he resigns but but still i was quite
upset to miss this
okay
hope you enjoyed
[Music]